so Carnage is one of the best stories
Marvel has going right now check this
out so what this does here is this
initially picks up with a kid by the
name of Scott and it basically takes
place at what's called Saint Estes
orphanage now this kind of just jumps
away from the Carnage story as we've
covered it right now we actually leave
the Symbiote behind but we encounter
something cool what is an effect the god
of gods when it comes to the Symbiotes
that are out there and it's going to be
the least likely person that you expect
so what ends up happening here is that
when Scott gets to Saint Estes orphanage
there's a kind of like uh history or I
guess maybe a series of myths and
legends this surround this house right
it's just your haunted house now some of
these are true and some of these are not
but the nature of the myths are things
that have just kind of grown in the
telling over the years as people have
visited this place for the purpose of
Thrills to like spend the night there
that kind of a thing so it's like
Waverly sanatorium out in Louisville
Kentucky right if you can spend the
night there's some kind of cosmic prize
for you at the end of all things but
what's nuts here is Scott's kind of like
live streaming this whole thing
intending to go into the house and to
check it out now on the outside this
house is about as derelict as it gets
it's falling apart windows are broken
all that kind of stuff because no one's
lived in Saint Estes for years right no
one's been here for years and years and
years but as soon as he gets inside the
house is immediately sorted out by the
houses immediately just clean and
pristine now what's nuts here is that as
he's talking to his fans writing starts
to appear on the wall and it says time
to put some skin in the game right and
then like a scalpel appears on the floor
now I'm gonna be honest with you guys if
this were me I would be like nope and
I'd leave
when writing starts appearing on the
wall on its own that's what it's time to
go if I even decided to do something
crazy like this in the first place but
Scott does it right it's all for the
fans it's all for the Thrills that kind
of a thing now once he does that he gets
into like the next room and there's just
a guy who's like eating a face right it
just says like feed the man some face to
eat Scott Ross and so now the house is
aware of who he is of course this guy
Apple's handed to him and Scott cuts a
portion of his face and then feeds it to
the guy when he gets into the third room
this disembodied voice kind of comes out
of nowhere and says let's turn this off
and we end up finding out it's Cletus
Cassidy now here's the thing right so a
lot of people are probably if you're if
you've been following the Carnage story
up to this point you're probably kind of
like I thought Cletus was in the mind of
John yes that is a facsimile of Cletus
so let's kind of bring everything into
order and let's make sense of it all so
those of you guys who remember our story
The King in Black when null the Symbiote
God showed up on Earth and took control
of all the Symbiotes and all that kind
of stuff there was a story that we
covered that took place after it that
was called Extreme Carnage right it was
a two-part story that we did really was
eight parts that we split it into two
you'll find a link to it it'll be in the
Carnage playlist you'll find a link to
it down in the comments the idea behind
this is that during King and black that
Iron Man had actually taken one of the
Symbiotes that was controlled by null
and then made it his own so in effect
Iron Man became a Symbian this is what
was called the extrembian it's really
the phrase given to it it was an extreme
just given the level of power that it
had what ended up happening here is
Cletus Cassidy who was already bonded to
the Carnage Soviet reached out to the
extreme symbiote and then bonded with it
now of course one of the things that
that sort of took place in between the
extreme Carnage story and this which is
actually explained later on in the
Carnage Comics which of course we'll get
to that there was basically a falling
out that the Carnage symbiote was
expelled from Cletus Cassidy and the
extreme symbiote and that's why the
carnota symbias doing everything that
it's doing right now but the extreme
symbiote has an immense level of power
because it was basically one of the
Symbiote dragons right crafted
specifically by null its power dwarfs
virtually all other symbiotes that are
out there and that's what's going to be
so crazy about this because when Cletus
Cassidy starts talking to Scott Woody
starts doing is saying things like you
came here to my house and you would have
left like all the others the moment I
asked for another piece of flesh but it
was the Rope you want to know how don't
you what he's referring to is that when
Scott got into the second room and the
man was sitting there eating a face it
was wearing the robe of his father right
Scott's father and his mind was like how
in the world did they know that my
father used to wear that rope now the
other part of what's going on here with
Cletus is that this is the actual
physical form of Cletus Cassidy which
begs the question what's going on with
John shade okay one of the things that
was recently established in Marvel
Comics is that whenever a symbiote bonds
to a host it leaves behind what's called
a codex basically a piece of itself what
Ram V seems to be doing here is he's
saying that not only does the Symbiote
leave a piece of itself in the host the
host leaves a piece of itself in the
Symbiote so the best way to think about
the nature of a codex or codices is to
actually look at Harry Potter right
Voldemort horcruxes Voldemort had put a
portion of his soul inside of an object
that's how codices work but a portion of
their essence of their being now if that
really is what's going on that the voice
in the head of John shade is the Codex
of Cletus Cassidy it's a whole new ball
game now right I'm speculating here
because we don't know for certain that's
what's happening but it's just kind of
my my thought process on that but the
important thing here is that this is the
actual Cletus Cassidy in his physical
form but the important thing here is
that as he talks to Scott where Scott
kind of asks him like who are you what's
your deal one of the things to know is
he's talking to one of the most
dangerous people in the entirety of the
history of Marvel Comics Scott doesn't
know it right but Cletus Cassidy is
insane he's like Marvel's version of The
Joker basically he's insane he's crazy
he's an answer to the question what if
the Joker became Venom that's really
what he was designed to be when he was
originally introduced but he plays it
very Coy and very Cavalier he says oh
I'm just an orphan boy who grew up here
in Saint Estes work the Shadows that
roam the Halls were so painfully boring
that I made up worse Devils inside my
own head I've been to so many places
since I have seen Beyond these worlds
and he says I've been tethered and
bonded and stitched in with things far
beyond understanding specifically he's
talking about null the symbiid God and
he says but I keep returning to this
house over and over I wonder if this was
my first symbiosis do you understand God
when I returned reborn in new skin in
new armor I melded in this place I am
this house and the house is me now what
he's referring to when he says that is
that at the end of extreme Carnage when
Cletus Cassidy was officially bonded
with the extreme Symbian he came back
here and actually bonded with the
physical house itself so when he says
I'm this house and this house is me he's
saying it literally it's not one of
those things where it's like it's such
an you know important part of my history
that you know it's very important to me
no no he physically is part of this
house he is the house right like that's
literally what's going on here it's how
the writing appeared on the wall it's
why Scott saw the man who was eating the
face they're all manifestations of what
Cletus Cassidy is creating he's
effectively altering reality in a
localized space it's kind of nuts right
and so Cletus says or at least he asks
you wondered how I knew about the robe
in the first room the piece of skin that
you gave the house took it and I used it
to look inside you and to find out who
you are I know you try hard to be
interested and Charming it's why you
sneak into houses at night armed with a
phone you want to know that behind some
door is a thing that is beyond the
mundane but Saint Estes showed me that
the real door that needs to be opened is
inside of you so tell me Scott do you
want to open the door to the next room
and that is a very important question
that Cletus is asking here because what
he is in effect telling Scott is if you
open this door there's no going back
there's no unringing this belt if you
step through you will never be the
person that you were before there's no
coming back from that and Scott
ultimately says yes now what's so cool
about this is that as he enters into
this room it's just kind of filled with
Penrose steps is all these different
aspects of like Scott's own life that
he's really being confronted with and
one of the first things he's really
confronted with here are quote unquote
the noises that came from his father's
room upstairs right whenever it is that
his mother was away the idea of him
being basically beaten and bullied when
he was a kid different things along
those lines these things that have
happened over the course of his life
that irrevocably changed him on a
personal level and what Cletus says is
the house is endless within Scott as
endless as you or I are on the interior
the only question is how many pieces do
you have to give now the beauty about
this and what Cletus is saying is the
house will change according to you every
room you enter will be a different part
of yourself but the things that you've
experienced and how you interpret those
experiences are endless because you're
experiencing these things as you're here
so sure there's the sound coming from
your dad's room upstairs when your mom
was away you interpreted that a certain
way the house will show you that but now
you're interpreting that interpretation
a different way and the house will show
you that too right it is literally a
manifestation of you and it will stretch
on forever but where Scott looks at this
is almost a kind of nonsensical thing
some Ploy some ruse right something
along those lines Cletus dismisses it
right and is like no right do not do
that and if you truly believe it is then
here's the exit leave right walk away if
you even think you can now what's really
cool about this right what's really
important about this is that it's almost
kind of toying with this idea that Scott
sort of passed across a kind of
threshold that there is actually no way
to escape here more so than that what
Cletus says is these things that I've
shown you are how you remember them but
just because you remember things being a
certain way does not mean they were that
way and he says outside you're just a
boy who discovered his father cheated on
his mom every night that she was away
outside Scott Rawson only grew up to be
another cliche who bullied others
because they reminded him of who he used
to be you're the bad guy and the victim
Scott that's what you are you remember
being bullied you were the one doing the
bullying that's who you are and he says
outside you try so hard to be the hero
of your own stories but the truth is not
romantic except by chance and the truth
is that you are small boring and
unimportant and where Scott asks is any
of this real the response of Cletus is
life claws away pieces of of who you are
until you're too old to notice and then
you die here I took pieces of you to
show you a different truth tell me Scott
Rawson which felt more real and that's
what's so interesting here is because
he's kind of alluring him right do you
want to become part of the house there's
the truth that exists out there but I've
taken everything that you know and
everything that you believe and I've
showed you the world as it really
existed along with a bit of recreation
of my own making which is more alluring
to you and the response of Scott is you
said you keep returning to this house
but you said you've been outside and far
beyond you found nothing in all
existence that could keep you there and
the response of Cletus is I found
someone once we were inseparable we were
almost a god of course referring to
Carnage and he kind of runs over the
events that transpired after absolute or
I'm sorry after Extreme Carnage which we
don't really get super in-depth in here
which is that there was quote unquote of
falling out if you want to call it that
between Carnage and Cletus Cassidy and
Carnage was expelled and of course again
Carnage is currently on his quest right
now but what he also says here and this
is what's so interesting is he says
Carnage is on his own mission out there
to try to attain godhood but what he's
going to find is that his desire to
achieve this life out there it will not
come to fruition it will not be what he
believes it to be that he's going to see
the faults in the stars and when that
happens he's gonna end up coming back
home it's inevitable because I've seen
the way things truly are and he says
this by saying it can change you that
kind of power that kind of perspective
they went away from me to see how far
they could go sometimes I wonder what
Carnage they must be getting up to but
then I realize they will see the truth
that I saw when it all comes full circle
the twinkles in the sky are only the
ghosts of dead stars and there's nowhere
in all of existence that is more
beautiful or more real than my interior
than inside this house here right here
still as I craft a reality of my own
making I can choose to be God and he
kills Scott Rawson I gotta tell you guys
this is probably one of the absolute
best depictions of Cletus Cassidy that I
have ever seen in the history of comics
because literally Scott Rawson stepped
into the mind of a serial killer and
died while he was there it was amazing
let me know what you guys think down in
the comment section right I loved this
let me know what you guys think in the
comments thank you all for watching and
I will catch you all later peace